معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي ان القوات
الروسيه وصلت التقدم في باخمت ومحيطها
وارفق المعهد في تقريره اليومي صورا لشركه
ماكسار عبر الاقمار الصناعيه وخرائط
ميدانيه تشير الى ان القوات الروسيه قد
تقدمت اكثر في وسط مدينه باخد واوضح
المعهد ان تقدم القوات الروسيه وصل الى
قرابه ثلاثه كيلومترات جنوب الطريق السريع
الرابط بين باخموت وتشاسيفيار وكوستانتين
من الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه للمدينه
هذا وعرضت مواقع عسكريه روسيه صورا لمقاله
انه المنفذ او انه المنفذ الوحيد المتبقي
للقوات الاوكرانيه من الجهه الغربيه
لمدينه باخموت باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وتظهر الصور ما قالت تلك المواقع الروسيه
انها اليات عسكريه اوكرانيه دمرتها القوات
الروسيه ووصفت المنفذه بطريق الموت